Tombo Tombo wrestling they're good how
could I just let you walk away and we
haven't let you leave without the tress
that's a good way to end it you guys
want one more yeah give me I want to eat
hey everyone lately I've been into
serial killer documentary yeah me too me
too
and sort of scale and things like that
sometimes I'll fall asleep while it's
playing and I'm worried that murderous
thoughts will creep into my subconscious
I don't have any history of mental
illness or anything whatever because
your your fascination is about it is
because the fact that you're a good
person and you cannot believe that
people can behave like that and that's
the interest because it's so far away so
can't even believe that people behave in
that way
it is I think that's probably why it's
entertaining because it is shocking like
we can't relate to any of that I've been
watching snapped a lot and I just want
to have any I just want to say this to
people okay if you're gonna kill
somebody just listen to me and you want
to make it seem like it's a suicide in a
staged suicide don't shoot the gun three
times once do it once once number two I
saw this one where this lady was like
yeah my husband you know I was gonna go
to work but I wanted to make him
breakfast so I put the breakfast on his
nightstand table right and then I left
and I came back and he killed himself he
shot the gun three times number one and
number two right and they were like why
is there brain matter underneath the
tray of the breakfast so this [ __ ] this
[ __ ] right kill them made breakfast
then put it on top of the [ __ ] thing
yeah think it through man three time
yeah
think it through and one of the bullets
was into the bed like it was in an angle
where it she shot the bed attica yeah
yeah this lady oh my god this you when
you watch shows like that it makes you
crazy not that I would ever kill anybody
but let me tell you something right now
if I were to kill somebody mmm I would
think a thorough how would you kill me I
would never kill you I but how would you
I don't want to go there come on tell me
love is too deep yours you would be
difficult because we have this podcast
because my sister calls your sister
she's always here got people yeah I
would have to kill other people to kill
you like Oh act okay like it take out a
plane I so that would be that would be
able to do it killing you and to get
away with it would be almost impossible
although I might be able to try to
figure out a health thing with your
heart you know that's what my doctor was
saying he was like are you sure Bobby
doesn't because you know all my heart
stuff happens in Raleigh I know how you
would do it where we stop remember wait
wait Europe doctor was implying yeah
that I was trying to kill you
dr. Santos why would I do that you know
what I would do I would just say it
let's just break up no not that you were
trying to kill no [ __ ] no thing I can
get out of this relationship I wouldn't
never [ __ ] kill you
[ __ ] your doctor you're trying to kill
me [ __ ] you did gained 12 pounds by
yourself you're killing yourself yeah
because I quit smoking that's true
that's why I'm not giving you [ __ ] oh
wow I don't get any like [ __ ] love
for that Oh quiet shut up I give you
real okay guy trying to do things I make
better my sight I got you I got a trophy
made for you a literal trophy I'm sure
it's been presented they don't show
enough love and support the ultimate
form of love every day sweetie you're
doing so great so proud of you are you
bastard so Bobby needs some tweets at
him your love and congratulations how
would you kill me how did you kill me I
already told you a cassava plant she
doesn't eat that stuff or like a
nightshade of sorts like the way you
would do it to her was like she's like
oh you gotta go to the hospital just get
surgery and as soon she's going down
with her was an aesthetic aesthetic you
see the doctor pulls mast
it's Bobby he just smiles yeah is there
I don't know I mean I would have to
fight at Google but then that's googling
but you know what I wouldn't go --gel
I wouldn't use you know mean I would go
you're good y'all a a library in like
Oxnard well it's good you know good to
Google chemicals and things that I could
pretend that you had a heart thing look
guys it's really not that hard to kill
me I know it's not that is that me I
don't want any traces back I have okay I
have a prescription for beta blockers
make it so that I take so many beta
blockers that my heart stopped no what I
would do no but I wouldn't yes I would
um go and look go to Oxnard library
right I would art like a disguise and i
Google things that's how I would be able
to Google like how would it kill you
know chemicals and things that I would
need to get sign they know how to figure
out how to get that delivered to me so
that's good but when people kill people
in snapped they just don't do it the
right way they disdain the bar they
don't think it through and it dress me
sloppy this is really negative under
Thanksgiving I got a baby I'm never
gonna kill you
[Music]